hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my fear The Walking Dead episode 1
video the videos that I do for this will
be just like the videos I do for the
main show there'll be six episodes of
this and then we'll get Episode one of
The Walking Dead Season six and just a
quick reminder new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video just to explain what's
going on with this show like if you're
if you're confused about why they're
doing a spin-off show they wanted to
tell more Walking Dead stories inside
this universe but they don't want to do
the exact same thing that they're
already doing on the main show so they
got a new cast of characters they use a
new location and it's set when rick is
in the coma that's when it picks up
eventually this show will catch up with
the main show in the timeline but it
said in LA and the survivors are in
Washington DC now so don't expect any of
the actors to crossover between both
shows just have some fun knowing what's
right around the corner for some of
these spin-off characters and as we saw
in the first episode they did speed
things along pretty quickly things are
going to [ __ ] really fast I think when
they first announced the show my biggest
fear was that we weren't gonna see any
walkers for like six episodes and that
that is totally not the case so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet I'm gonna do my top ten
moments and then do like my final thumbs
up thumbs down on the premiere starting
with number ten druggy walker communion
great way to open the series it looks
like nick's character here is
auditioning for the flash season two i
guess i guess maybe there's fewer
walkers up in vancouver right now where
they film that seriously nick spent like
half of this episode running I bet you
whenever they were auditioning actors
they were like okay you're going to be
running a lot so we hope you are
physically fit LA is most definitely not
a pedestrian-friendly City I think the
reason that they opened on a walker is
just to let you know yes there are going
to be walkers in this series they're
just they're going to have a lot more
skin than the walkers in the main show
moving that's number 9 meet Travis and
Madison's family very very broken family
but still family nonetheless what really
sets the characters in this series apart
from the characters on the main show is
that on the main show nobody really knew
each other that well when they first
came together but the spin-off show is
going to follow like this core family
unit or this kind of amalgam of families
you basically got two different people
that are divorced that have come
together Kim did
Ekans Madison character in Travis's
character played by Cliff Curtis they're
like the two leads but they're both
divorced and they have kids from other
marriages that are all they're all just
trying to figure out how to get along
the reason I think that they opened on
Travis fixing the sink is so that you
know that he is a handy person like he
has skills that will help him survive in
the apocalypse that's really what this
whole first episode was about showing
you that the characters have certain
skills that will be helpful whether it
be stealing things or critical reasoning
or investigative abilities if you got to
number eight meet all the characters at
the school which is just a bomb waiting
to go off
both of the main characters work at the
school if that wasn't clear Travis's
character is a teacher looks like
English Lit teacher in Madison's
character I think is one of the guidance
counselor's so we meet like a couple of
the other big characters there though
there's the principal who won't stop
talking about the flu shot which makes
me wonder if the flu shot actually
helped the virus spread around the world
really fast especially if the virus
accidentally came from some
pharmaceutical company Tobias is really
like the most interesting character in
this situation though he's like one of
those kids that nobody listens to the
Lisa Simpson you're going crazy no we're
not giving you your knife back
which is why way way later in the
episode when everyone fails in the
school and he gives her that I told you
so look is really satisfying but you I
mean everything's going to [ __ ] so
you're not really celebrating moving on
to number seven meet Travis's ex-wife
and his son Chris with her they weren't
really big in this episode so I'm
expecting them to be much bigger in next
week's episode just because it seems
like these two families are going to be
coming together like Travis is trying to
build this new life with Madison and her
family but he still got his family that
he's trying to deal with it'd be like
going on a date and having your
ex-girlfriend and her new boyfriend come
along too and then suddenly the
apocalypse breaks out and you're stuck
together sounds like an awesome date
almost as awesome as this church date
Nick went on if you got to number six
Alicia and Matt teased that they're
going to be having a party because his
parents are out of town just total setup
for the most cliche Walker attack ever
you could almost say that they're paying
homage to like some of the classic rules
of horror movies like teenagers getting
into trouble when their parents aren't
around and a bunch of people wind up
getting murdered so Matt being that he
didn't show up later in the up
so seems like he's gonna be total Walker
bade Viviane's number five
everybody bails on the school as they're
talking about chaos theory it was a bit
of a heavy-handed joke I mean you know
when things get as obvious as that but I
like that they had them looking at their
phones at the attack on the freeway this
is the real world of course YouTube
exists so people would be talking about
[ __ ] going crazy and I also thought it
was really authentic the people were
questioning if it was real or not like
we're so post parody that it's hard to
believe when crazy things happen
sometimes you're like well whoa this is
way too crazy very clearly they're doing
some sort of skit some sort of setup
speaking which number four she goes down
on the freeway the funny thing about
this is that it's also very true to life
that the freeways in LA get backed up
all the time in the episode they take
off after they hear a bunch of gunshots
but really that's like any other day in
Los Angeles that wouldn't be normal at
all most people wouldn't think twice
about it I'd like the way that they
connected that with the later scene of
them looking at the phones like with
what they were seeing on the phones was
what was happening when they were stuck
on the freeway moving on to number three
Nick kills Cal and then runs off in case
you missed it earlier in the episode
he'd been stealing phones he stole a
bunch of clothes he is kind of like the
Daryl Dixon he's like a younger crazier
version of Daryl Dixon on the show
better suited to life in the apocalypse
than he is in life during normal
civilization he understands how messed
up he is but the skills that he has like
stealing things heat like he finds a
cigarette on the ground and just picks
it up those are things that you would be
doing in the apocalypse you'd be in
scavenger mode constantly and they had
that whole Jack London nature battle
speech role in the episode and they were
kind of putting forth Nick as being one
of the dogs like that was actually
backed back in the hospital where it's
like the dog is nature nature always
wins and then and then like it cuts to
the scene of him in the hospital with
the bedpan and she's like I take my dog
out when I want not the other way around
you're the dog in this situation so Nick
is nature Nick will always win so they
were kind of telegraphing that he was
going to be getting himself out of crazy
situations which is why when Cal pulled
that gun I was like well clearly he's
gonna fight him off and then he's gonna
run away in the body's gonna disappear
everybody let me know if you're going to
go Reed White Fang now - if you get to
number two Travis
Madison in Nik go back to check out
Cal's body if it wasn't already clear
like on their way there you can kind of
hear Madison talking to herself she kind
of knows what's going on with Nik with
the drugs with kal like she probably
understands the cows not the greatest
guy but the whole deal with that body
was just erase any doubt in their minds
like that was proof that Walker's exist
and Nik is not crazy that's why they had
him like run over him three or four
times and then he kept getting back up
kept getting back up
that last time that he hit him with the
car and it knocked him way way far away
that actually knocked his foot off in
like the bottom half of his jaw so like
we know when he turned around that was
proof for the characters that zombies
exist or you Robbie obviously we're
talking about walkers in the Walking
Dead universe and finally my number one
WTF moment the preview for the rest of
the season as you can see like I mean
you know small sub communities are going
to give rise to certain characters that
will try to take power the military
moves in it'll be kind of like a crazy
version of Woodbury which is why like
this other main character that they
teased here I'm wondering if he's gonna
be like the governor figure like the
person who tries to take power someone
who wasn't a huge deal before the
apocalypse but things go crazy and they
use that as an opportunity to rise to
power let me know that was you guys
favorite moment from the episode
generally I mean there's only six
episodes so they're going to be speeding
things along pretty quickly by the time
we get to the last one it'll be like
full-blown Walker apocalypse I can't
remember exactly but I do believe it's
been picked up for season two already I
think that they announced that a long
time ago but just in general I'll give a
giant thumbs up to some of the themes
that they were able to weave across the
episode they're very consistent
especially with the Jack London and that
was some really nice imagery big thumbs
up for the actors they cast Kim Dickens
is one of my favorite actresses she
plays certain types of characters so I
feel like she works better in this
context that she would in the main show
she's kind of like a slightly more
hardcore version of Carol Pelletier
before the apocalypse
you remember how different Carol was
before the apocalypse cliff Curtis is
great too
really like they wanted to hammer home
that he's a good guy he's not a shame
character he's not going to go nuts with
power they want you to know that he's
going to be like the Rick Grimes of this
series he's a human being he makes
mistakes but he is a very
good character at his core it took me a
little while to warm up to Nick but once
I started seeing shades of Daryl Dixon
inside of them I liked them a lot more
there's still a lot more that we have to
see though I mean it's going to take a
couple more episodes before we meet the
rest of the cast so I'll be interested
to see how I feel about the series after
the next couple of episodes so what's
going to happen next is I'm going to do
a Q&A for this in the season 6 preview
that I posted earlier and then I'm going
to do a game of Thrones bonus video like
I would normally do there was just way
too much Sunday stuff for me to do my
normal game of Thrones bonus video the
only real thumbs down that I get to the
episode is that it feels a little self
contained in that Los Angeles is a huge
city so clearly like not everything is
going to be as crazy in certain parts of
town as in others like we saw Venice
Beach which is on the west side we kind
of saw the east side we kind of saw
downtown a little bit there just like
there are a couple big areas that we
haven't been to yet like I'm wondering
if we're going to go to Hollywood if
we're going to go up in the hills
somewhere there's LA is looks like a
really big place just in case you guys
haven't seen it yet you can click here
to watch my Walking Dead Season 6
preview there was a little bit of
footage just teasing like the biggest
premiere ever I think it's going to be
bigger than season 5 episode 1 and I
just posted a trailer for Gotham season
2 you can click here for that thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you